hi YouTube I'm Jim Shiro the CEO of
Zurich Financial Services about three
weeks ago we announced a significant
climate change initiative exert I know
many people are concerned about given
the current financial crisis grill a lot
of these climate change initiatives get
back to the back burner I'm confident
that that's not going to happen I think
that extremely important that climate
change become part of the solution and
restore economic growth with the
establishment of innovation and
creativity we begun offering products
around ensuring carbon capture methods
and we've also announced a reduction ten
percent of our own carbon footprint
during this period of time I think these
are cost-saving message methods that
will help us in our businesses but I
think also people are too aware at this
point in time of the danger that the
climate is in the let's take immaculate
so I'm confident that as long as CEOs
keep this on the agenda we won't lose
out during this current crisis